you ever notice that every time the
democrats have a crisis the fix they
propose always seems to attack our
pillars of western culture
why do democrats seem obsessed with
tearing down things like family and
religion these are good things right
because it's all part of what they call
the great reset
folks the left can't stand conservatives
they hate what we stand for they hate
that this country is built on object
built on objective truce they hate that
your big r god-given rights exist
but you already know that
the answer is
why do they hate these things and it's
found in what they call the great reset
it's because you are in their way
so what's the great reset
the world economic forum is a globalist
organization of self-professed elites
the founder and chairman is klaus schwab
who literally wrote the book covet 19
the great reset and made it a focal
point of his summit in switzerland in
2020.
if you want to read up on the great
reset there's an entire page on their
website dedicated to how they want to
start over with year zero
but listen don't take my word for it we
always bring receipts here here's schwab
singing the praises of communist
president xi jinping of china at his
summit last
year polarization has created the age of
disagreement
which threatens to derail humanity
now
we must come together to ensure that we
capture the moment and move into the age
of collaboration
to build a better world mr president
i believe this is the best time to reset
our policies
and to work
jointly for a peaceful and prosperous
world
so what does this have to do with
democrats
because in order to reset the world
liberals must first get rid of the old
one
and that's why they constantly attack
religion and family
the real power struggle here folks is
between objective truths and the
absolute power of the state
the family and religion are competition
for the state and the left
and there's nothing they hate more than
competition and a meritocracy
let's start with religion for centuries
but especially in america religion's
been the bedrock of society
here's jordan peterson explaining
exactly that to joe rogan
categories just
dissolve especially fundamental ones
the culture is dissolving because the
culture is a structure of category
roughly speaking we have a bedrock of
agreement
that's the bible by the way it's that
the bible is the precondition for the
manifestation of truth
which makes it way more true than just
true
it's a whole different kind of truth in
short we get our objective truths from
religion that's competition for the
state so democrats have to attack it at
every opportunity again they want to
wipe out the competition
christians of all people are supposed to
be particularly worried about their
neighbors and this is also a really
critical situation where if you're not
vaccinated you may be the one spreading
this virus a subset of christians who
support trump who believe that god has a
very specific
call on his life it's breeding this
degree of fanaticism this degree of
religious fanaticism that i think could
have real danger because let's face it
republicans this is not really the face
that best reflects your party's values
this is
remember back in 2012 when democrats
took a vote to reintroduce the word god
in the language of their platform it
barely passed listen to the booze
the motion is adopted
and the platform has been amended as
shown on the screen
thank you very much then there's the
nuclear family we all think it's a good
thing right with religion no not for the
left this is a big hurdle for the
marxists to install the great reset they
got to get past that your kids well they
don't belong to you
they belong to the state according to
these marxists
here are just a couple of headlines to
prove it see at the washington post and
cnn an unlikely cause of our bitterness
that the nuclear family these are real
headlines
they can't stand this it's in their way
you can see these headlines right there
the left is dedicated to using every
possible means to tear our nuclear
family apart
to do this they create a divide between
the children and their old and outdated
parents
so that the kids will voluntarily
dissociate with their family values
while the state's in complete control
their education they hate competition
and once you see this
once you recognize it you'll see it
everywhere you can't unsee it
it's in the blm movement the lgbtq
movement education and politics
progress it's the reason that your
grandparents views are better not spoken
in public
people who have been cast adrift by the
breakdown of the nuclear family they've
lost touch with one or both parents and
they're sort of floating and they come
together and say you know we'll be a
family together a school in new york
city defending itself after telling
students not to say words like mom and
dad
apparently they think it could be
offensive instead of mom and dad say
grown-ups folks or family yeah
stop the bill that i don't think parents
should be telling schools what they
should teach
the chicago's teachers you chicago
teachers you did saying out loud by the
way that your kids belong to them
we see it
it's right there they're telling us who
they are believe them
and here's education secretary miguel
cardona
echoing the world economic forum's
talking points just days ago
we can't lose this moment
this chance for a reset in education
by going back to the same pre-pandemic
strategies that didn't address
inequities
listen i get it there are skeptics who
could possibly doubt what i'm telling
you is true despite the evidence being
everywhere so how do i know we're right
here
i just listen to the left
especially when they tell us as i just
said exactly what they're doing and what
they're going to do
they are who we think they are
like using the pandemic to take your
freedoms so that the state can be in
charge of giving those said freedoms
back to you
and we have a very narrow window to tie
reopening policy to vaccination status
because otherwise if everything is
reopened then what's the carrot going to
be how are we going to incentivize
people to actually get the vaccine so
that's why i think the cdc and the bond
administration needs to come out a lot
bolder and say
if you're vaccinated you can do all
these things here all these freedoms
that you have you catch it did you catch
it she says the state grants our
freedoms you know not by god or anything
like that there's a state thing is it
but listen it's not all bad news here's
one of the so-called elites themselves
at the world economic forum a couple of
months ago admitting that most people
just don't trust them
the good news is the elites across the
world trust each other more and more
so we can come together and design and
do beautiful things together the bad
news is that in every single country
they were polling
the majority of people trusted that
elite less
folks you know how to tell when
conservatives are right over the target
with the great reset year zero this war
on family and religion well the left
they send out their army of you know
fake fact checkers to call everyone
conspiracy theorists this is from
reuters just days ago look at the quote
despite repeated misinformation being
shared online about the great reset this
sustainability plan proposed by the
world economic forum is not a secret
plot to end private property or create a
totalitarian state
every single time hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else